[Music]
well I was a new guy on the block I'm
not a kid at this point I'm like 42 43
[Music]
the scene would be Rick Deckard meeting
Rachel who is we don't let this point is
a replicant we think is simply an
extremely beautiful one it's artificial
rick is being introduced to Rachel by a
man called Tyrell Tyrell is the head of
this giant corporation probably
wealthier than bigger than anything that
we know of today and it's in a sense it
becomes a kind of competition between
the skill of Rick Deckard as a as a
Blade Runner and deducing whether or not
Rachel in fact is a human or otherwise
in the scene there's this device which
is called a voight-kampff machine which
measures the blink and Irish reaction to
question therefore in a funny kind of
way is a perfect lie detector and Rick
sits at a table and opens up the machine
and focuses on her eye and so has given
questions
what's the killing jar to the doctor to
Rick Deckard it's just a job replicants
are like any other machine he appears to
be oblivious to the beauty and is
unimpressed by what he sees and at the
end of it he says how can she not know
what she is how can it not not know
cause her it so obviously she's a race
apart
[Music]
so done a lot of fashion a lot of Chanel
things like that intelligent commercials
but I was this would be my third film in
and so I was very we're very very very
aware of cosmetics and I didn't love the
hair in the first day so I said you know
what can we take the hair down and so
what I did i sat in that and kind of
fundamentally went through the hair a
game and the makeup again I think ended
up painting your lips actually and our
always thought of an actress I think I
mean hedy lamarr it would had us of a
severity which was spectacular of course
it is
I'm making this film at a time when
digital doesn't even have a word I said
how the hell do I differentiate between
a replicant I need to have light in
their eyes in the way that the Leopards
eyes in 2001 and I said how the hell do
I do it I wanted there occasionally so
it's not insistent it becomes too
robotic every now again I want a glimpse
so you said let me think about it this
is typical Doug who came up with a a
simple half mirror you have a sheet of
glass which is half bear and the mirror
is mounted on the camera in front of the
lens at 45-degree angle on one side just
behind the camera is what in those days
we'd call a pup a very small light which
is on a dimmer you just turn it up with
the subject sitting here looking
straight to the camera you turn up his
light which is reflecting from the
mirror into the lens has not been
photographed in the camera and and what
she moved he got golden light on it from
the restaurant genius house I was
accused in my first all my films I've
been accused of being too visual too
brilliant going well they are dealing in
pictures so how could I be too visual so
I was very defensive of what I do what I
did shows a tray of water with mirror
top pieces in the bottom if somebody's
doing that hard light and the lights
doing that lapping off the walls
there was the set of the sets for the
shining so one evening had drifted into
the ballroom where the bar was in the
corner and that was pretty spectacular
set when I saw the film the barman came
on and it was Joe took oh I went there
he is
and I wanted a kind of almost comic
strip the darkness of a dark comic show
and I searched her comic knife found
these glasses and we made him
indulge me Joe god bless him 30 years
old looks exactly the same as he did
then I think he's pickled
[Music]